[Music]
what up people we are at the final
episodes of Scott Pilgrim takes off John
Hario I am not ready to let go G man how
are you I am
I'm yeah I'm going to miss it I'm going
to miss it decided decided In This
Moment oh good guys leave a like thank
you to everyone who's been here for this
journey with us also big thank you to
all who have joined us over at our
patreon page uh for Scott pogm take us
off we also cover several things over
there exclusively with highlights and
watch alongs included that is where you
can catch the full length R and watch
along where you sync it with your own
copy all righty guys let's see what's
going on and also thank you to preer for
helping us set down these highlights
let's get to
[Music]
it what do we
got
oh homeboy travel through
time and
space what time
travel oh it's a Scott Pilgrim Focus
episode the Scott overse excuse
me is it a multiversal
Scott is that what we're going to
get like maybe he planned it but he
didn't plan it what even is any of whoa
nice
what is becoming of him
oh who are you show why you're the
greatest Warrior
Scott The Last of Us this is my exact
thought it's the wrecked set where are
we Toronto
Canada is he the narrator the future oh
who John your Scott Pilgrim 37 years old
still
awesome I Am Legend
Scott two Scott two
Pilgrim so
we hell happened in Canada yeah might
even make it to 40 if we're lucky it is
Will Forte are we rich and famous do we
win a lot of cool fights we do okay the
fact that we can grow a beard alone
alone somebody appreciates
it it's not that far in the future I
know said literally somebody making the
noise my
mouth
Whoa We Live Here No way here let me
show you our house did you actually
purchase it or is it stolen or is cyber
Punk Canada just still so polite and
affable that you could just kind of walk
up and claim it Oh What a Beautiful
home this looks like Lucas Le home but
that's in Canada this is in Canada this
is in Canada the league of evil xes that
takes me back whatever happened with
that no let me break it down for you
fighting those xes was the biggest
mistake of our entire life oh because we
lost no because we won yeah buddy so
this is like a sequel kind of yeah a
requel you have virtual reality Game Boy
we have it all the future's more
futuristic than they originally
predicted future is more
futuristic Cod Secrets the
P oh my God somebody in this life is
going to build themselves A Classic Game
Boy vault door welcome to the VR chamber
virtual
guy give this one is oh I did miss you
Scott
memories virtual
guy me and Ramona Ramona and I that's
that one guy I know him and that guy
they don't look so tough that guy just
skateboarded to his death God they're
Chumps it's movie yeah so Ramona dated a
robot that's Progressive no no she dated
the twins they're humans yes another red
flag pal I don't see any flag and it's
all red she's like Princess Leia oh we
get married this is really sweet
actually what goes wrong minions I love
it oh Universal Studios yeah this is a
really nice project man oh is that that
that's not part of it anymore ignore
that one I I told him to take that out
next
screen
divorce now this one looks like it's in
a completely different style it's the
exact same if not better no it's
definitely worse whoever did this is bad
at art oh that's the end of it yep
technically we're separated after the
honeymoon 12 13 odd years later we must
have had some good times oh sure but
those aren't in the
simulation so he's just completely and
utterly alone Scott Pilgrim versus the
world I'm talking about my new band Popp
and twinby the members are me and the
twins I told you about the twins though
right you're in the league you said we
defeated them oh yeah but after they
respond at home I guess they learn their
lesson or
[Music]
whatever oh my
God
[Music]
love that it's half in
Japanese this is really capturing this
kind of music videos
Man loving
you it's a Bop right over a 100 views
over a 100 how did he gain all the
success
says hey why is all of old Wallace's old
stuff in our garage where's Wallace now
when I said our house you thought I
meant me and you knock knock you boys
want some ice Silver Fox Wallace SCS
yikes nobody mentioned Sonic the
Hedgehog it's 39 all it's a call back to
Sonics to the first episode yeah how can
old Wallace affords such a big house I
can afford it it's kind of a sugar daddy
situation sugar
oh
hey
bird he's going to find out one way or
another all right I I didn't want to do
this so soon but he's right what what
are we gay Wallace's husband works at
Nintendo where they make the video
games get every game for free yes he
doesn't that's not true it's true they
get every game for free I thought you
said it was a sugar daddy I'm really
really really happy for you oh please
you're seeding with jealousy get your
own husband who is your hubby this was
your idea I'm sorry yeah when me and
Ramona were having problems you said too
bad I don't have a time machine so I can
go back and stop myself from dating her
in the first place oh no oh no how the
hell did you get a time machine in the
first place that technology hasn't even
been invented yet
oh one of the twins do you think time
travel is
possible hm
[Music]
he's reti but get the robot out of
retirement he would experience the
entire duration of his existence
simultaneously
whoa which would mean in theory at least
sure yeah time travel kid stuff
easy here's a simple pie chart for you I
took you away from Ramona on purpose see
I used to have a heart it was right here
it's gone because she tore it
out you can tell me what you did wrong
and I can go back and do a better job
you immediately assume I messed up yep I
do the dishes I walk the cats I make the
spaghetti I won't take you back to the
past until I know for a fact that you
won't date Ramona Flowers because she's
the one who's bad news not us oh boy a
jeez it's never good when your future
self comes to you remember how you were
after NV Adams dumped you it's like that
time 10 I like how this is a pure
reflection of Scott it's whole season I
like it's not I like this
idea I like this idea a lot yeah didn't
I see you at the rocket back at our show
in the past did you happen to get any of
that on video you record video of
everything he's going to see his entire
life everything everything all at once
oh and he could experience via VR
nice peace
[Music]
nuts
whoa yes was he connected to the past
there yeah may I guess so maybe the
Scott who's been the robot who's been
watching has just been Scott yeah just
like Scott keeping an eye on all this
stuff and peering in throughout the
season and so old Scott also wrote the
script and gave it to Young
Neil
interesting but the script is about him
winning Ramona's heart age don't ask she
can't be roughly 30 to
40 I love how she actually looks young
still
yeah oh
no stop we come in
peace the tea I heard about old used
idiotic time travel plan convincing
himself to stop being obsessed with me
has he met himself that's why I came up
with a backup plan he has met himself
now one of your dumb Friends wrote A
Memoir Scott and Ramona and me my
precious big life as Scott Pilgrim's
best pal my old
[Laughter]
young oh yeah if old Scott was going to
erase everything I wanted there to be
some way for you to discover our story a
I sent it back in time you have a time
machine too too they're made out of
parts from an old DeLorean when I hit 88
M hour I travel through time oh my God
except Scott doesn't read books but I
thought of that so I moved some scenes
around combined a few characters and
before I knew it oh oh like a real
biopic so young Neil did write it that's
crazy in a way in a sense yeah the plan
may have been misguided I just I had to
try he's the love of My
Life the movie fell apart careers ended
that's not the story I
saw it's the friends we made along the
way it's the closure you got with all
your evil exes so yeah man he was
watching the Ramona I left she was
looking for me looking for answers never
giving up like that famous detective
Columbo I was going to say detective
Pikachu yes you're Rona sounds pretty
cool so cool I love the music in this
show it's very
transportive into the
purse 88 mph here we go but what is it
in
kilometers Trail and everything hey baby
miss me how's work Wallace you do have a
heart so that's why you're steaming wait
is future me here
hey well hi uh I got to get a picture of
[Applause]
this so funny just P right out right oh
thanks knives so fun I met someone so
I've gathered I'm really sorry and maybe
this isn't the best time to have this
realization but I probably shouldn't
have been dating you in the first place
oh wow Scott I'm glad you're
alive but I'm also glad you
died gave me a lot of space to reflect
and grow so
thanks
a
[Music]
yeah what what what is it metaphorical
nope what
the what the [__] what if I still have
to fight your exes how much did you see
on that futuristic VR thingy I'm pretty
much caught up then you know the game is
changed but the players are the same
Ramona could fight them with her with
him yeah they can fight them together
somewhere you could find all the exes
gathered together at the same time to
celebrate musical theater yes the
show precious little
musical this is such a fascinating
culmination all seven evil xes in
person
Dizzle they got him by still
yeah and he's still got his ulterior
motives
whoa not bad not bad
rcta whoa turkey leg oh my God could be
plant- paste it could be a toe furky leg
true then it's time for the big
finale let's
go roll
credits
I'm excited yeah me
too I we've seen these credits multiple
times yeah I still have not caught the
narrator wow the orchestra
Tunes oh my God St okay now double that
and we done oh my
God oh my God your bows are going to
explode out your
stomach
oh come on evil X number three Todd
Ingram right oh he's got to go in
different order vegan let's fight me
fight you over Ramona and I'm vegan no
longer I had a cheese plate for
breakfast lunch and dinner today whoa
you owe me a new tub of butter
popcorn you are wal's roommate tell me
everything where was he born what is his
middle name does he have a favorite
vegetable still a vegan left in there
somewhere I'm not interested in Kurds
and
way there were Sparks there's no such
thing not even fire
[Laughter]
Sparks God do not be throwing hands at
me right now this is the biggest night
of my career I shouldn't even be wasting
my voice on you so really doing right
here in the lobby yeah you're the
freaking star you didn't create a force
field preventing me and Ramona from
kissing did you that evil villain stuff
is behind me I've got Jewels
now the hell is going on Lucas
Lee also cleared I don't
know let me tell you about Broadway bad
boy Matthew
P whoa do either of you know anything
about this force field thingy and would
either of you like to fight about it
nope come on let's go watch a stupid
musical about a stupid guy is bored as a
foot with a mouth like the hand with a
mouth lo I know it was the ex's who made
it Scott Pilgrim's precious little
musical we're not here to fight our
robot says we're all bros in the future
so later
bro we've ruled out all my exes no
fights no kissing this finale
sucks n it'll get better don't
worry
whoa God there's like a sea mine up
there some hot fuzz
[__] very cinematic shot yeah damn one
like the subtle like
fishing Scott Pilgrim so you got the
girl you going to kiss her or what kiss
her kiss her all support
Jesus
I'm Scott Pilgrim I know shut up I had
that dream again I didn't care the first
time you told me I care even less
now
evil
evil wow Scot you seem so upset this
such a great medley bread makes you fat
bread makes you fat what's wrong with
that yeah oh yeah had a
[Music]
plan
whoa what
is are they all getting Su into the
future the world versus Scott Pilgrim
attack still not cool Goose
enough
oh lens
but old no even older oh mental health
and wellbe unknown 47 years
old how you doing love the white
hair whoa he's so buff I explicitly told
you to stay away from Ramona but did you
listen
no
wow
this show is so cool yeah man got me
twice with this gotten Ramona Must Be
Love hey give us a kiss you two let's
see those Sparks oh it was you it was
the even older one I had a backup plan I
guess it was Nano machines in your
drinks of course you'll find the AK
Fields they generate to be quite
impenetrable you son of a [__] anti
field
[Music]
yes so why are you here fighting us
because winning didn't change anything
we still end up marrying
Ramona oh your stupid friends must team
up at some point in my new past and
figure out how to dissolve the anti-k
fields oh wow I respect the work you've
put into this villain plot but I have my
own villain plot going on we've got no
beef with you what if I have a beef with
you oh let's go it looks cool
man
wow he's just gotra Powers somehow Scott
Pilgrim returned after you left the
future and after old Wallace kicked me
out I began my training yeah 10 years I
did nothing but study all of your skills
your strength your weaknesses because
there's only one way to end
that
me versus the world
yeah Scot versus
everyone oo this is a true anime yeah
h plus 10 against
Elders oo damn no anti-p punch fields on
those damn
come on even older Scot and someh just
kind of rooting for you
oh Rona are you okay wow this is a turn
of
events oh what we
got oh yes oh
cool it's time to to down Chow
Down
awesome
wow love
yes
whoa oh my
God it's kind of like that Hunter Hunter
we just
watched level that's great extra
powerups
O Let's Go
skater die
ouch she still got the tattoo I love
they took the time for
that this isn't even my final form look
at the
punch it's like anime in the best
Nintendo fighting
games
Gordon
damn so weird to almost be rooing for
Gordon hey no there's no way there could
be the end of
it Scot he's got to do this alone oh but
he's got Ramona
oh god let's hit them together wait huh
yes of course
[Music]
ah nice you need to let me live my life
if I do you'll end up where I ended up
alone for 10 years that was your choice
so extreme yeah
you oh my god what if what if he's right
he's you you think I want to become that
guy I won't oh my God
yeah
whoa future Ramona yeah or even more
future
Ramona 10 years then Wallace tells me
you're training to go back in time and
fight yourself a lot of people we hit
one rough patch and you go completely
insane oh no fighting all of these
people yeah and uh robot when you could
have been fighting for us this SC in
them
yep are you saying that we weren't over
are you saying that you still loved me
at the time yes
oh so what about me you're telling me I
should just skate on call it another
failed experiment no no run run away
from the thing that you love
oh
oh my God the show's giving me exactly
the thing I complained about two
episodes ago
yes yeah oh my
God always skating
away I'm done running huh such a great
movie line you yes I Choose You A
selflove Ramona in the power of
selflove hug yourself Scott super
Ramona just like super the hedgehog
three I mean
three kick his ass super Ramona no no
it's never too late to clean up a mess
but I will send him home so he can get
started oh well this is great
not the me who left him and the me who
just met him we're the same I see that
now it's all the same
who
yes yes yes
[Music]
[__]
hey Sparks because I'll have a lot of
trouble saying it later let me say it
now I love you Scott a but what I've
done in the past doesn't have to Define
me it's all your fault help me keep
remembering that
okay super Rona
yes the
Rona
a
Sparks
a he's
flexing is there any way you would take
the Empire back just let me keep my show
and the rest of it is yours of
course everyone gets what they want this
was his ultimate plan L yeah just to
make some
[Laughter]
friends
we
2 okay yeah
[Music]
hey yeah
knives
epilog are they going to perform for
Envy
or do they write a song for
Envy stun actress yes she black widow or
she a
star no we need physical media make
out without
you hey you got a job there nice a
oh my God he's made for this Superstar
Barista Lucas Lee At Your Service
whatever uh whatever yeah whatever damn
so annoying but the tips are good and I
do get to look at his butt all day
that's America's ass I'm spending the
money I got for starring as myself in
this major Canadian motion picture that
never got made have to make her Nintendo
must
be the die one more ASMR
you think she's going to have a smile
this time it's a smiley face hair do
certainly feeling lighter smile
hey feeling
[Music]
free nothing cooler than her guitar
nothing cooler nothing feels
cooler there is no oh Doug surewood
there's nothing there's no greater
discrepancy between what feels cool and
what looks cool than air
guitar oh stepen root was the Nan
machines time for the real game to begin
the goose is loose honk
HCK teas for the second
season testal
combat
yeah they played this song uh in the
first episode oh okay
yeah dude all right so okay let's
immediately rank it is it better than uh
is it better than the movie come on book
process confident answer right now
without go this has at least more
breathing room to to maybe uh create a
different sort of more nuanced emotional
impact w wow recency bias wow I mean the
nothing beats the movie screw this I
don't like art at all unless Edgar
Wright made
it that means my pool of art is precious
limited God you know what they should do
they should go to reject Nation shop.com
that would help me decide get some real
rejects apparel there that's a great way
to support the channel look as fly as
everyone in the show you get shirts like
this RR shirt that I'm wearing and it's
my favorite way you can support the
channel it's John's favorite way you can
support the channel it's your favorite
way to support the channel know you
don't know yet but look at all these
shirts oh my
God involved ourselves in all these cre
for every different day of like half the
month I know exactly which shirt is
flashing on screen on which point to I
love that one the most we I don't even I
might have even talked longer than
necessary and we're just now we're
having to repeat shirts and we run out
of shirts to flash let that start over
again yeah look at them shirts oh look
at these shirts then to start showing
like thumbnails videos you should
watch keep going through and through and
through and through
oh man yeah that was fun that was great
I think those last two episodes it was
funny cuz like the pen the Penultimate
for us but not the real penultimate
penultimate 2 I found myself craving a
little bit more development for Ramona
since the focus was on her yeah and it's
a fun little flipper a great inverse of
things where you find out that it's been
from Ramona and Scott's perspective this
entire time the character you spent the
most time with is Ramona however it has
also still been from SC perspective yeah
which is really cool yeah it's a great
way to uh make you go see we didn't go
we we didn't we fully pissed that
certain crowd off they just needed to
not Rage Quit long enough to get here to
see it they just need to get her to the
end um but the the author behind this I
don't know any of the behind the scenes
information on it but the the telling of
this is great because I I really feel
like it captured the heart underneath
the caricature of everyone here and like
especially by the time you get to the
end it it really seemed like it had a a
softer sympathetic approach you can feel
the writer going you know I like these
guys and I want to see a little bit more
of the love underneath everyone and how
at the end of the day all these people
who have become obsessive freaks over
Ramona H they're all broken individuals
yeah and this is is a significant
motivator for various aspects of their
lives that they might not be able to
admit not everyone got like the most
development I would say you know like
the twins didn't really get development
and I mean it's a it's a nice subversion
but yeah it's like they don't get really
get a fight or anything like that and
and when they do show up it's almost
always kind of just facilitate something
and I thought like while they had a in
the live action movie at least uh I
while I liked their sequence with the
music battle the battle of the bands uh
it's still they were still like the
least interesting characters to me
because they didn't really get character
yeah they didn't really speak much you
know so like their fight is the most
interesting thing about them but they do
get them a very important plot Point via
creation of the robot yeah and I mean
the Nano like they're they're the the
the accompli and the like R&D department
for so many of the minations that that
affect Scott and Ramona throughout those
yeah th% man I mean I thought the show
was very beautiful and it it's an
inspiration of like 80s and 90s video
games uh and Anime and and it really
feels like an embodiment all of it it it
doesn't just feel like it's something
that is on the surface level paying
homage there's something that speaks
from a genuine part again it's the word
that keeps coming to mind is you can
feel the soul behind it not just notes
of things they wanted to attempt it it
feels
naturally from within that is coming out
when I say the word expressive I'm not
using that word lightly because it
really does feel like an expression of
Soul here yeah it's super evocative like
it it has so much kind of emot emotional
richness to it and that sometimes in
small you know little ways that are kind
of precious and then in other times it's
in big overflowing ways that are very
sort of uh all-encompassing or very like
relatable in a in a grander way and uh
and yeah like this while you don't spend
a lot of time with Ramona and Scott it's
still an epic Love Story 100% because
you feel the you you feel I car way more
about this love story than I did in the
movie yeah yeah I would agree and you
feel it kind of from both their
perspectives and I like that it lets you
sit in the bitter sweetness that love
can be because I mean there's so much
like the rush of Love uh you know can
can often come with that sort of like I
don't know it's a different kind of Rush
it's almost like the rush of falling uh
literally when you know that love is
threatened or that love is called into
question in any way shape or form and
and you know there's so much about
uncertainty and this culminates in a way
where it's like don't let your you know
fear of the f future based on the past
you know wreck your present almost like
I thought the way that it wo it's like
we've seen this in things before and and
even recently especially with like the
older version coming and finding the
young version and it's like kind of
wondrous or fun at first and then it
turns out dark but I thought this was a
particularly nice Lightyear yeah
Lightyear uh uh
flash uh you know various it's a Trope
that that is a well-worn Sci-Fi thing
that's a passion the Christ to is about
definitely I'm like Jesus listen maybe
we shouldn't get on the
cross maybe we should just deck Judas
right there you know take those pieces
of silver start a church of our own you
know if I just embrace the socio and
economic essentially with the Last
Temptation Of Crisis oh reaction ain't
never seen it that isn't Jesus coming
back isn't isn't it Willie defo is uh my
man is my man jez yeah yeah I want to
see it I want to see oh my God I should
make Willi the fo Scott Pilgrim he would
be a great older Scott Pilgrim if they
ever made another liveaction movie I
think that'd be really funny if they did
that but uh yeah we've seen this thing
of of of the older self coming back and
it being a grim cautionary Tale But I I
really like the way that they
complemented that by bringing Ramona's
in as well and then giving the greatest
payoff in a sense to her in that moment
complemented everything that came before
and especially as she is you know like
so much of the story is instead of it
yeah being Scott sort of learning to uh
not be insecure about all these evil
exes it's more about Ramona learning to
let go of all these people that she
pushed away because of yeah her own uh
fear like you know sabotaging for fear
of of this thing failing you know self-
sabotage yeah it's a story of self-love
as well yeah self forgiveness you know
yeah and and and I did feel for them
wanting to wanting to make the love work
mhm there's a bit of an Eternal Sunshine
vibe to it yeah cuz it is that thing of
like well you know we're going to spend
the time together but ultimately it's
going to wind up in tragedy and maybe
it's just better to never have to deal
with that and it's also kind of like the
time machine it's that thing of like if
you the the more you try and avoid
something the more you're going to bring
it about so why not just live in the
moment but it's still an arc for Scott
too you know like seeing who he is in
the future like it it goes past the
movie yeah and like it doesn't I thought
maybe they were going to go extremely
meta where you
see where where Scott's look the
alternate version is I feel like the
implication is for future Scott older
Scott is here's what happened after the
movie that's kind of like the the
implication yeah right um and they you
see that they didn't have a happily ever
after but they could have just made it
work if he matured yeah but he like
jumped ship too early instead of working
through it you know yeah and and he just
became an obsess of Escape of uh
individual too like he never truly grew
up and he never fully realized yeah what
the real thing to blame was yeah so I
think uh they both get like a character
Arc and it shows that for the
relationship to work they both have to
work on each other's individual things
yeah and not it's not just a story about
them realizing like oh I need to learn
one thing about myself like it goes
deeper than that and again it doesn't
feel like pretentiously deep it because
the movie the show still keeps it
extremely Whimsical extremely vibrant uh
everything is like ramped to an 11 here
and uh and and I thought that it was
also very tender and nuanced I was I was
really impressed with this show man it
gave us something in very very different
and it it took a tad bit of readjusting
and a little bit to see where it goes
but I also get why this is a bin show as
well yeah this actually feels like
appropriately B this one of those shows
that could work as either but I actually
think it's better as a binge the
well-roundedness of the story I think
Will Shine especially bright if you
binge it but I do think that remarkably
especially for the the to be on the
platform that streamlined and created
the the
structure you know the literal structure
of shows that bolsters this binge format
you know this is an example of of
something that's not just I make sure
it's got a gripping opening and a
gripping Cliffhanger it's like these
actually function well as pieces they
feel like issues out of a greater like
compendium and yeah like they do
absolutely work on their own but as you
know we kind of talked about on the last
one after episode six like the totality
I think yeah Will Shine really really
bright as uh just one whole go yeah I
like Ramona Flowers way more here than I
do in the film as an honest take and I
like Scott more yeah yeah it's kind of
weird because Scott's not in it as much
but I I do like Scott and Ramona more
yeah and I think again if you've seen
the movie I think that balances out
nicely because we've spent work as a
good companion yeah like it's funny like
the characters are well written and well
drawn in a way that makes it so that
yeah they compliment and then I think
just you know the the other thing too is
like it's really nice that all these
actors are also really solid for the
voice acting they need from this yeah uh
cuz not everybody translates um and and
yeah there's something about I think the
fact that you know we know Michael Sarah
so many of us have seen the movie so
we've spent the time with him and then
the first episode I think giving you so
much
familiar I never felt like he was too
far away even when I didn't know that he
was like watching over things with the
robot and yeah like Ramona is a solid
character and it's like while you know
in the movie both their flaws are also
represented like this is yeah it's like
you can see her involvement in all this
and it just I don't know it just seemed
you you you could see her her
involvement in spinning the web that
we're dealing with right now or at least
yeah but but but also how really quick I
mean for how how young Scott got Ramona
to realize that the older Ramona to
realize that hey you know the the
Journey of of Scott being taken out of
the equation and and losing to the X
instead actually LED Ramona down a path
that was better for her like the healing
process that she went through and
everything so inadvertently by Tak him
out it actually it made things better
for everybody yeah it made things better
for literally everybody yeah except for
older Scott but you know it's a great
subversion cuz because you you don't in
any way miss out on the fights and the
action which is fun and and then the
dynamic flips around and you sort of
find what else these people have to
fight for and like yeah there are
confrontations but yeah I just think
that's like a such a nice
rich like it would work without the
movie and I think it's a really nice
play off the movie because yeah instead
of
guy fting to a prove his adequacy to and
wi the heart of girl yeah this is just
such a more qual it's like it's a very
appropriate thing to do for the here and
now and people winge every time you make
something from a female perspective that
has a man's name in the title but you
know it's her story in so many ways and
uh and yeah it's absolutely a just a
lovely thing they chose to do yeah I
think it's really cool that they made
something
that I I think the cell on it I think
that's probably the problem with the
marketing is the cell makes you think
you're just going to watch like an anime
version of the movie yeah and they don't
re I mean they want to leave you
surprised which is also like the great
thing about it um
however I I don't know I feel like maybe
there was there could have been like a
quarter maybe not a middle ground but
like a quarter leaning into that we're
really going to do something very
different you know and take it a very
different different direction sure
without spoiling it I don't really know
I'm not a mark I'm not good at marketing
so I don't really know what the [__] it
would be however uh yeah like I think
it's a great I think if you watch the
movie and then you watch this they work
perfectly together because and I think
this works better if you see the movie
yeah 100% you just you there's there's a
lot more yeah it'll be a fuller context
like I think this is super rich on its
own but yeah there will be a much Fuller
context and I and too I don't know it's
one of those things where they made all
these changes but I don't feel like it
in any way betrays any of these
characters and it's nice to see these
cartoons take on you know in the
liveaction movie they are certainly
cartoons and then get a character like
Lucas Lee or or any of them you know
really but you know to give them flesh
and flavor and heal certain things
Beyond just the thing that makes them an
evil ex like all that stuff is fun but
we find fun in other parts of them and
in ways in which we don't need to keep
them broken in these specific ways and I
think that's just a nice maturity of of
characterization yeah and just yeah his
whole like that that one thing Brian
leali said about like approaching this
as like a sort of reflection on as a
means of making it its own unique thing
I think is a beautifully rendered
Approach at least by this final product
yeah I thought it was amazing man yeah
this is really terrific I thought it was
really amazing beautiful animation all
the way through
shot like everything felt handrawn uh
even if it isn't it felt handdrawn every
shot felt incredibly selective
everything felt like it hadp tender love
and care you know every element felt
this you know just feels like Living Art
you know the way you say the the kind of
compliments you would give across the
spiderverse I would say they keep that
consistent here for every minute of
every one of these episodes yeah it has
that or or it almost has like
spiderverse has it and even different
sort of kind of thing but everything
everywhere all at once or or just things
that have this like mad cap quality and
they're throwing like so much at you yet
they also have such a Keen Eye and a
compassionate eye towards just emotion
and character and and nuance and things
like that and so yeah you feel like you
just took in this semi overwhelming
thing that has so much in it and yet
somehow despite all the potential that a
spiderverse or everything ever or this
present this somehow feels like a
definitive version well it's also so
self-aware the way how they they keep it
modern day but they imagine it in the
way of like how would someone in the '
80s or 90s devise this plot yeah you
know but by keeping him like I love when
he goes to the Future and it's like not
that far in the future but everything is
like a dystopia um [__] like older Scott
dystopia yeah an older Scott is is like
so old even though he's just 37 years
oldt but they play it like that that
classic thing that you would see in like
' 80s like Wallace is just gray yeah
exactly same gray hair yeah like that's
exactly like how these 80s movies would
do somebody make their hair gray and now
they're older and now it's just 10 years
from now but they're so much older yeah
yeah totally and just like I don't know
the way it incorporates all it's like it
has specific pop culture references but
yeah the way it amalgamates just so much
uh yeah of like retro futurism and and
in in fun silly ways you know there's so
much here it's exciting had punch I love
the original music that they had
throughout as well you know normally
with Scott Pilgrim you kind of think
yeah like they have the music that is
created within it for like the
characters using it but I'm just talking
about like the when scenes are happening
and you got a bit of that yeah um like
eight bit chip tune kind of yeah yeah
it's a good way to put it it's a good
way to put it um overall man I'm like a
I'm like a I don't know I I don't know
what I would really criticize about it I
thought it was pretty near perfect for
what they set out to do honestly yeah
yeah absolutely I agree
99999999 yeah just give it a just give
it a 10 just go for it yeah yeah John go
for it all right I'll give it 11 thanks
John you're welcome it's an extra point
for the both of us really good yeah
anytime all righty guys well what did
you think of Scott Pilgrim takes off do
you prefer it over the movie do you uh
put it on the equal measure what do you
rate the show as a total experience
leave your thoughts down below
be sure to subscribe leave a like and
hey let's send this with
a pandemic Jones pic PJ my friend it's
been a while since we've heard from you
my buddy um but I imagine right now that
you are probably in a Multiverse and
exploring alternate versions of
yourselves and one of them is someone
who does create a pandemic himself and
is an evil mastermind because his heart
was broken or and then you see another
Universe where hey uh he is just a
reality show chef and he uses his clout
to get laid and Skip lines at movie
theaters and then we go to another
Universe of pandemic Jones where he is a
woman the hottest woman on earth and you
use that to skip lines at movie
theaters the there it's always at the
movies no matter what universe
there's another pic Jones and a universe
full of where everyone are are their
they their Cricket people they're just
walking crickets and what did they do
they go to the movies and at a theater
you could jamack thousands in one
Auditorium so that's why ticket industry
is booming so often times the weight
line is atrocious and complex yes and
you're always hearing crickets but
that's good because that means the
Crickets are like in the movie are
relaxed and enjoying it totally and if
you want the best scene in the house you
are the president of cricket planet and
pandemic Jones is skipping lines yes
using a secret service to get past
security and get through the crowd of
crickets in order to watch movies that
uh are essentially our films just
crickets Bug's Life Bug's
Life is a very it's a very serious drama
there exact same film but a horror
it's Terri they have to deal with
[__] oper it's a play on real world
history on that planet and they like
don't profile us we're not grasshoppers
it's not the same it's not the same and
uh yeah no I I I Feel You Man The
Cricket planet is rough so uh
surprisingly it's one of the more Grim
realities I'm sorry you never guess it
but dude um either way uh you are
someone with a lot of prestige and
admired on every planet you go to but
out of any democracy to be a part of
reject Nation admires you the most so
much love to you thank you for being
part of our page and supporting us for
so long and uh chirp chirp my friend
chirp
[Music]